precisamente hablando de esta reunión
que ha convocado Emmanuel macron con los
sindicatos qué se puede esperar de este
encuentro con el fallo del Consejo
constitucional ya ha cerrado
Hola muy buenas tardes Pues la verdad es
que con este fallo que puede ser o
gasolina para el movimiento social un
jarro de agua fría Esto es lo que es un
poco la incógnita vamos a ver qué es lo
que sucede en las calles las próximas
semanas con las nuevas movilizaciones Es
verdad que el gobierno El Ejecutivo
parece querer sentarse a dialogar con
los sindicatos exclusivamente cuando el
asunto ya está zanjado es decir cuando
ya no se puede hacer absolutamente nada
lo vimos en la reunión que tuvo
Elizabeth Board con básicamente con la
intersindical con los distintos
sindicatos donde se les dijo de antemano
que sí se venía a dialogar pero sin
tocar los puntos clave como
efectivamente el retraso de la edad de
jubilación por el momento efectivamente
viendo que el gobierno que El Ejecutivo
no está dispuesto a dejar a soltar
absolutamente nada y que al mismo tiempo
yo no hay ningún recurso institucional
al cual se pueden aferrar ni opositores
parlamentarios ni opositores en las
calles realmente se abre un escenario
muy muy y precisamente estos días No
estos cuatro días de aquí al martes
pueden ser clave en términos de la
presión que hagan las calles para este
encuentro del martes entre el presidente
y los sindicatos
Sí la verdad es que es que vamos a ver
vamos a ver cuál es la respuesta vimos
por ejemplo en el
decretazo
tras la aplicación 49 vimos que el
movimiento social tomó otra forma dentro
Digamos como una especie de segundo acto
no en el que vimos Pues muchas más
manifestaciones espontáneas por la calle
por la calle de noche con un público más
joven etcétera etcétera no entonces
veremos si en esta ocasión entramos
digamos ya en un tercer escenario en un
tercer acto del movimiento social que
efectivamente va a venir marcado Pues en
los próximos días Vamos a ver
probablemente reacciones ya de manera
inmediata no en las calles